ce qui m'a le plus fait peur c'est
surtout le fait qu'ils ne disent pas à
demi mot qu'il est là pour installer une
société de la vigilance quand la
journaliste lui pose la question d'une
société de surveillance il dit
simplement que pour lui c'est une
société de vigilance c'est la même chose
ça veut dire que c'est une société où
les libertés deviennent finalement
l'exception plutôt que la règle et plus
ça va aller et moins nous aurons de
liberté je suis et vous le savez en
train de dénoncer le pass annie terre
depuis le début de la mise en place de
cette liste de ce dispositif clairement
on voit que la feuille de route va aller
plus loin techno surveillance
biosurveillance le drone la cnil a beau
alerté on a vu la faillite du conseil
d'état du conseil constitutionnel nos
libertés sont en danger avec le
programme le projet d' emmanuel macron
enfin je suis pas d'accord avec vous là
dessus mais moi je pense que ce n'est
pas la pire chose qu'il ait faite mais
ce qui l'est moins ce qu'ils m'envoient
serait plus chez lui c'est vraiment non
seulement il est auto centré mais en
plus on a l'impression qu'il est seul
c'est vraiment le roi soleil qui
illumine tout le monde et qui attire
tout à lui fin et il n'a évoqué aucun de
ses adversaires directement et surtout
aucun de ses alliés aucun de ses
ministres le premier ministre c'est ça
n'existe plus premier ministre et en
bulles ministre on se mit à même pas son
parti à me passer des ventes et il est
seul et il alla il à la vraie parole et
il a soutenu d'ailleurs sont en même
temps ce vingt ans ne sont en même temps
en disant c'est parce qu'il est juste et
efficace voilà donc lui c'est ce qui est
juste et ce qui est efficace il ya
aucune discussion là dessus